okay so this talk is fantastic neural
nets and where to find them
so we'll go I'll go over the Wolfram
neural net repository and we just make
this a little bit bigger so everyone can
see properly okay
so today you're going to learn about the
the Wolfram neural net repository so
I'll start by going over a little bit of
the background for the neural net
repository so you will learn about
general uses and features then you will
get a guided tour where you'll find out
how to navigate the Wolfram neural net
repository after that you'll learn about
the anatomy of a net model so the
metadata associated with the resource
object as well as the components of the
net model and then I'll go over some
examples so you can learn how to
actually use these net models and then
very briefly I'll go over submitting
your own so you can learn how to use the
definition notebook okay so a little bit
of background for the neural net
repository so a little bit about why
this resource was created often working
with neural nets can be difficult or
frustrating because there are many
different frameworks and different
places that you might have to go to
actually find the models that you want
and then once you have a model sometimes
you have to train it yourself and which
involves getting the data set the time
and the resources involved in training
when you're constructing your own model
you often don't want to start from
scratch you want to start from something
where you can use some of the layers
already to kind of make what what you
are actually looking for
so the neural that the Wolfram neural
net repository makes this easy for you
by having everything in one place so
it's very comprehensive we have a large
assortment of high-quality net models
and they are updated regularly with new
model so when we see a new model to
convert we put it in there all of the
models come pre trained which saves you
training time and it also saves you the
headaches because sometimes training
steps are not publicly available so
there would be no way for you to train
your own model based on that data set it
the best part is that everything is
available within the Wolfram language so
there's no need to import from other
frameworks you can just use our
framework the net models can be used as
is their pre trained and ready to go you
can the layers can be added or removed
if you want to construct a new model we
also have an untrained version of the
net which you can train with your own
data if you'd like and you can submit
your own either privately to use you
know for your own purposes or you can
submit it publicly if you'd like to
share it with other people if you think
it's useful okay so now a guided tour of
the Wolfram neural net repository so if
we go here so this is the neural net
repository we have it set up a lot like
the data repository there's a little bit
of information about the repository
itself and then it's organized by task
type so we've got classification we've
got feature extractors we have image
processing nets and we have regression
nets and then if you notice within each
of these there's there's a title and a
little bit of information about what the
net actually does and then if you hover
over the little images here you can see
which input domain this take so
basically this net model will take as an
input image data whereas for example
these will take text as the input we
also have audio models coming and
numeric models coming as well so there's
also different ways to search through
this so if you wanted to just search by
input domain you can do that you can
pull up all of the image models and
again you can just see the title and the
description here and then you can go to
the actual model you can also browse by
task type we also have an option to just
look at everything that we have in
alphabetical order so you can look
through this and say you are looking for
a ResNet model you could go straight to
R and you get all the rezident models
that we have we also have search
available so if you are looking for
ResNet models you could just type
ResNet and then we could return all of
president models we have that way
also on this taskbar you'll notice
there's a contact us so you can fill
this out if you have suggestions
questions concerns if you have a great
suggestion for a model that isn't up
here you can put that in so there's
there's a bunch of different things that
you can request from us and then let's
go over just one of the shingle pages
and if you click up here you go right
back to the the landing page so let's go
over one of these so say one of these
image-processing ones so you'll notice
we have the title the the brief
description of what it does there's some
more information about the the details
about you know how it was constructed
when it came out a little bit of
information about the size before you
download it we also have this nice
feature which is training sent
information you can get information
about the training set that this was
actually trained on and if you click the
link you can go straight to where the
data came from and then very you know
these are all very similar to the data
repository you can download the example
notebook which is exactly what you see
on the screen here these examples you
can open it in the cloud so these
examples show you a little bit about how
to use the resource so how to retrieve
the resource object how to get the pre
trained net and then some of the you
know the more of the the gusts of what
these models actually do so this model
for example you feed it a satellite
photo and it creates a a map for you
also on these shingle pages we have
information we have the construction
notebook so if you click on this you can
download the construction notebook which
bring this sorry so you can see here we
have oops sorry wrong notebook there we
go
so
the construction notebook which shows
you not only how to use some of the
pieces of this but also shows you how it
was actually constructed so what the
parts are for it and then some of these
construction notebooks will show you how
it was trained others that you know the
training was was done separately so we
have that also on this shingle page you
can see we tell you the Wolfram language
requirements so this particular model
works with eleven point two or above it
will not work with eleven point one so
that's something you want to keep in
mind and then we just have a reference
where we have some information about
this is the paper about the model this
is where to get the model itself and
then this is the rights associated with
it okay so all of this information is
also available sorry
through the Wolfram language so if you
move on to the next slide so you can
access the metadata of the resource
object right in the Wolfram language so
if you evaluate this you'll get this
little box that has a little bit of
information if you hit the plus sign you
actually get a little bit more
information and if you want even more
information you can do if you do
resource object and then properties get
all the properties that are associated
with this I won't go over all of them
I'll just show you a couple just to show
you what's involved with getting these
so let's say we wanted to see when this
is last updated we would put in the
latest update and we'd see it was
updated in February of 2017 if you want
to see which version of the Wolfram
language you would need to use this
resource I mean obviously it's in the
title for this one but in case it wasn't
you can see you need 11.1 to use this
one you can even like I showed you
there's a way to open the example
notebook to view the example notebook
from the website and also to open it and
download it from there
but there's also a way to get it
straight from the language if you just
do this
and of course it's popping up on a
different window sorry about that so you
can see the separate notebook will open
and you can just you can use it just
like you would any other notebook and
it's the exact same information that's
available on the website and then each
net model has a set list of components
so if you do resource object and then
content elements you'll see there's a
construction notebook evaluation that
uninitialized evaluation net and then
construction notebook expression you can
kind of just ignore the construction
notebook expression that's mostly for
internal purposes so we have that there
and so the evaluation net is actually
just the pre trained net so if you you
can do resource data and type in the
model name or you can do net model for
specifically for the neural net
repository both work so if we do this
we'll see we get our trained net model
you can see all of the different types
of layers that are in it and the size of
those layers each net model kind of has
a different graphic for these so some of
them you can see the layer some of them
you can see a graph it really depends on
which one and then you can also get the
the untrained Network so if you want
that one you would just do see inside
the brackets you do uninitialized
evaluation net and you can see it says
uninitialized right on it and the other
things that would tip you off to that or
these layers are red so you can tell
that this is an untrained model so this
you could train with whatever data that
you wanted and it just has the
architecture of the net model and then
you can also get the construction
notebook I showed you how to get it
straight from the website but you can
also get it with from within the
language so if you do this another
notebook will open and it has basically
the same information and like we just
went over this has information about how
to get the construction notebook the
uninitialized evaluation that and the
evaluation then
and then information about how the model
was actually constructed okay so next
I'll go over some examples of actually
how to use these so we'll start with an
image from Star Wars and we'll go just
with this image for all of these we have
several models that are for general
purpose object classification including
wolfram image identify for Wolfram
language 11.1 we also have image net
models Inception v1 v3 vgg resonant we
have a bunch of those so we'll just get
the net model here and you can see the
net chain and then we're just going to
feed in this image to the net model and
see what it thinks is the main object in
the image so we get Chewbacca so it's
been well trained the top five guesses
here so it's pretty sure that it was
Chewbacca but it also could be some
other kind of ape or hair slide I'm not
quite sure what that is we also have
object sub I typing a model or basically
it'll count the number of prominent
image items in an image so again you can
get the net model here so its inception
v1 trained on extended salient object
sub I typing data so if we feed this
image into this model it correctly gives
us two we can also see all of the
probabilities so it only goes up to an
interval of four to infinity but it's
pretty sure that there are two objects
in that image we also have a scene
recognition model called Inception v1
trained on places 365 data and this will
tell you the scene in the image so if we
feed at this image tells the system's a
beauty salon so that's not completely
accurate all the time if we get the top
10 guesses we can see it wasn't really
that confident about beauty salon but it
was the most confident about that we
also get some you know silly ones like
Science Museum or music studio or
Natural History Museum so
you know sometimes you can get some some
pretty funny results out of these
depending on what you feed it we also
have a geolocation model which is pretty
cool so it's ResNet 101 trained on why
FCC 100,000,000 geotags data so if we
get that so basically we can determine
the geolocation of a photograph so if we
give it this photograph it'll give us
latitude longitude coordinates of where
it thinks this photograph was actually
taken and if we plot that position on a
map comes up with New York City which is
as good as guess as any for something
that happened in in space we can also
obtain the top 50 guesses so these are
all the the geo positions that it's
guessing that we have and then if we
plot these on a world map with the so
the size of the bubble will indicate how
short it is of where this is so it's
pretty sure that it's either in New York
City year somewhere it looks like Paris
but there's also these other guesses
that this is where it could be and then
if we move on to image processing
example you can see we've got a
colorization net so basically if you
have a black and white photo we can run
it through the color net image
colorization trained on image net
competition data you can see this one is
actually net graphed you can see it's a
little bit different than the last one
but you can see how all the pieces kind
of fit together here so basically we
have a black and white version of this
photo if we feed it into here we'll get
the a and B channels of the LAV color
space we can find out what the
dimensions of that is and then we would
need to write an evaluation function
that would merge the a and B channels
with the luminescence of the grayscale
input and then we can evaluate this
photo on the evaluation function and see
what happens and hopefully it will
colorize it
it does you can tell it's not exactly
the way that the original looked please
most well we can't scroll back that far
but you know looks more like a sepia
photo but it's it's definitely been
colorized we also have depth map
regression models so there's I believe
three of them in here we'll just do one
so the single image depth perception
that trained on depth in the wild so if
we evaluate that we can get the depth
map of the of the image there we go and
then we can visualize this and so you
can kind of see I mean it's not perfect
but you can kind of see you know the
depth of Chewbacca's face the sort of
gun here and then Harrison Ford's face
you could also do 3d visualizations on
this so this is a little bit cooler so
you can see much better the sort of 3d
quality of that and this one even is
slightly better because it looks more
like the photograph so if you kind of
turn this around you can see you can see
that it's sort of a 3d photo now we also
have a style transfer network which you
may or may not have seen so this is ADA
in style trained on ms Koko and painter
by numbers data so basically what this
net' does is it takes the content of it
it takes the content of one image and
restyle z-- it in the style of another
image so if we use this as our content
image and then a famous painting as a
our style image we can restyle the photo
there we go so now it kind of has this
abstract quality to it we also have a
built-in function called imagery style
which uses this net model as the part of
the backend but it kind of resizes
things so that you'll have something
that is more in aspect ratio so you
notice like this kind of got squished
and this one is more of the correct size
and comes out a little bit differently
but you can see you know it's a it's
about the same kind of abstractness and
then we have some facial analysis models
as well so basically all of these models
run will only work on facial crops if
you if you tried to run them on an image
of this size the the results often come
out incorrectly so what you have to do
first is authorities find faces in order
to crop these images so that we can just
run these images through these different
models so we have an age estimation
model age estimation vgg 16 trained on
IMDB wiki data and let's see how old it
thinks these faces are okay so it comes
out incorrectly for for both of them but
we can see what the top 10 guesses are
so again you know it doesn't it doesn't
have a super high probability for either
of these that 13 is the correct answer
but that's the highest one we've got we
can see the entire range of the
probability distribution I believe that
red is Chewbacca and blue is Han Solo as
you can see especially for Han Solo's
sort of a bimodal graph so really it
should be saying somewhere around here
because that's how old Harrison Ford
actually was when he shot the film but
but clearly you know sometimes you get
slightly askew results there's also a
gender prediction net based on the same
its trained on the same data
you can guess the gender of these faces
so it correctly guesses that both are
male or at least I assume Chewbacca is
male it's not quite as sure about
Chewbacca as Harrison Ford but that
makes sense because this was trained on
human faces not wookie faces we also
have a facial keep we have a couple
facial key points Ness what we're going
to go over just one of them so this one
is the vanilla CN n for facial landmark
regression so if we get the net and then
run these faces through these are the
key points so it gives you eyes nose and
mouth corners we can visualize these
predictions by setting different colors
for these the different points and you
can see it's fairly accurate it's got
both eyes the nose and the mouth corners
for both faces and then we also have a
3d facial model so you can essentially
make a 3d model of a face from a 2d
image it's unguided volumetric
regression net for 3d facial
reconstruction so if we run this image
through there we can see the dimensions
of the volume and then we can visualize
the model so this is pretty cool we can
get kind of the this is sort of a 3d
rendering of what Harrison Ford's face
looks like it's actually kind of neat it
looks like it's frozen in carbonite
and then we can this is just another
version of that so you can see we can
get just just the face model okay so
that concludes all of the examples that
I'm going to show we also just like the
the data repository we have a way of
submitting your own neural net resource
which I won't spend too too much time on
because it's very much like the for the
data repository you'd fill in all of
your information here you would put
information about the training sets that
you're you
you only need to put in your evaluation
that here we will from this notebook
we'll get the examples we'll get the
construction notebook as long as you
fill in these fields and we will get the
untrained Network from the Train to
network and just like a data resource
you know you would create a resource
object here you can deploy it locally
you can deploy it to your own cloud
which is often a good way to start just
to see what you your going to come out
with before you actually submit it to be
publicly displayed or I mean if that's
all you want it if you just wanted a
resource that you can have constant
access to you can publicly deploy it to
your privately or publicly to play it to
your own cloud and then if you get a
publisher ID and you would like to
submit a resource you can do that
through this resource notebook right now
this definition notebook is not
available on the website but it will be
shortly in the meantime if you would
like to submit something if you're if
you're just dying to submit something
you can do so you would just need to
contact us via the contact us button and
we should be able to help you with to
walk you through how to actually do that